welcome back well there's a new
injectionist at chic lovey the sponsors
of this next segment that want to help
you achieve your ideal aesthetic we
stopped by to get to know her and what
the med spa has to offer
[Music]
[Applause]
hi my name is pamela cordova i am a
registered nurse here at chiclevi med
spa i focus mainly on dermal fillers and
neurotoxin injectables
for the overall face
i've been in aesthetics for the last
five years but i also have a background
in post anesthesia and post surgical
care but for now my main specialty is
all cosmetics when patients come in you
know they kind of start by saying areas
of the face that bother them whether
it's fine lines
deep set wrinkles
from there i kind of go into their
background and their overall appearance
and goals and we focus on treatments
like botox for wrinkles of the middle of
the brow the forehead around the eyes
and we can also do fillers to add more
volume and restore the overall health
and plumpness of the skin all my
patients they kind of range from early
20s to even late 70s injections is for
everybody it's not as taboo as it you
know used to be back in the day it's not
just for older generations
younger girls are coming in to prevent
those lines from starting which is a
huge thing now because we've come to
realize that injections are a lot of the
times preventable and it's easier
to start younger than it is to chase the
lines that have been there for many
years i also offer dermal fillers which
is a gel-like substance that's made up
of hyaluronic acid the gel or hyaluronic
acid is injected into areas like the
cheeks the lips around the mouth jawline
just to enhance their natural features
and to smooth out any fine lines and
wrinkles
if a patient's complaining of lines
between the brows or on the forehead and
even around the eyes we can use
neurotoxin injectables like botox or
dysport to prevent those lines from
forming since i'm new here at chiclo v
we are going to be offering some
introductory specials on our website and
social media so come check this out you
can also schedule a consultation with me
where we can go over
some of your skin care goals and things
you want to enhance on your appearance
thank you to chiclavi med spa for
sponsoring this segment they are located
on sahara boulevard inside smith plastic
surgery to make an appointment and for
more information you can call
702-233-8535